this is a message from the collective  are you overly tired or experiencing  increased sensitivity remember physical  contact or displays of feeling are  danger to all of us let's do our part to  help contain this disease did anybody  see that  anyone recognize him it's her first  jumper in a while  I'm watching you the way you look at the  world the way you experience things  start out it's has to stop if it  continues I'll be forced to report you  I can't stay away can not be around you  you realize man what happened do not  risk your job do not risk your life all  I need to remember how it was to feel  I was told to keep an eye on you is  there something you want to tell me you  know what are we gonna do  seriously considering this if we stay  here we'll be found out if you make this  decision there's no turning back  I need to remember to feel alive just  remember what this feels like  you